I'm gonna start with with the most
casual question I have why are we here
like in the largest sense of the phrase
okay promotion I met like on earth I
think that's what they meant decided to
procreate like the parents that came
before them and here we are I didn't
sign up for this anyway it's a really
funny holiday movie good morning Hank
it's Tuesday I'm here on the let it snow
like press junket huh and I'm here with
we're gonna you know we're gonna switch
to Netflix as good cameras now what's
your favorite Christmas movie of all
time I'm up at Christmas Carol Wow yeah
yeah mine used to be it's a wonderful
life but that did y'all film in the snow
yeah and they added more snow on top of
snow do you remember the coldest day
it's minus 30
oh nothing sensible kidding how many
marshmallows is optimal for hot
chocolate I take them and I make like a
top layer of marshmallows and then once
they all disappear into my mouth I add
another layer who would you most want to
be snowed in with easy yeah yeah yeah
yeah I feel like I would annoy you Isaac
are you saying this because your answer
is not me Oh doctor your ass no of
course it was you it was always do you
have a favorite holiday song Alvin and
the Chipmunks Christmas
this question is very important to me
what is the appropriate time to start
celebrating or decorating I'm on the
fence you know I believe in people who
do it you know right after Halloween and
people who do it after Thanksgiving and
I think we're all really good people and
we all should work together to become
better people are you running for office
have you all seen it I watched it with
you it's genuinely great I've seen you
I've seen you all in other things you
did without us and they were all so good
letting is your favorite gas station
snack stations in Australia where can i
watch
let it snow November 8 not just under
memory
really good point but especially on
November 8 but also on November 9th yeah
Hank I'll see you tomorrow